[Musique]
cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous Mina
Cavani bonjour bienvenue sur ce plateau
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes actrice Franco
iranienne vous êtes à l'affiche du
dernier film du réalisateur iranien
jaffarpanaï qui purge à Téhéran une
peine de 6 ans de prison pour propagande
contre le régime le film s'appelle aucun
ours on va y revenir dans un instant
magique ranavard c'est le nom du second
manifestant qui a été pendu hier à
Téhéran en public on en parlait à
l'instant dans le journal il avait 23
ans il a été accusé par le régime du
meurtre de deux bassidy qu'est-ce que ça
mord signifie pour vous
la tristesse absolue je depuis hier que
j'ai entendu cette nouvelle
je suis complètement brisée tous les
Iraniens nous sommes complètement
j'ai envie de vous dire on est en deuil
ils sont en train de tuer nos jeunes ils
sont en train de massacrer tout le monde
et
je pense qu'on est connaît pas
suffisamment entendu et qu'on a pas
suffisamment soutenu par le monde
occidental nous employez le mot brisé
c'est ce que vous avez écrit aussi hier
est-ce que ça veut dire que la stratégie
du régime qui est celle-ci précisément
briser l'espoir que peut
amener cette révolte en train de
fonctionner oui mais il faudrait que
vous sachiez que nous on arrête rompa et
qu'on va continuer même s'il y aura
encore et encore et encore des
exécutions nous on va continuer et que
de toute façon nous avons commencé un
chemin dont on peut plus partir en
arrière ça
après maintenant ça commence à être très
très violent ça va être encore plus
violent je pense mais
on va continuer vous avez écrit sur la
photo de ce jeune qui a été pendu hier
que vous écrivez votre silence est un
soutien à ces criminels à qui s'adresse
le vous
j'adresse notamment au monde occidental
parce que je pense que comme je vous ai
dit nous sommes absolument pas soutenus
que mon devrait être soutenu je vous
rappelle le moment où il y a eu George
Floyd qui a été écrasé par ce policier
américain il y a eu le monde entier qui
s'est relevé pour lui et nous par jour
on a des gens qui sont des jeunes des
enfants qui sont en train d'être tués
exécutés prisonnier et on a cette
impression que c'est beaucoup plus
normal pour les occidentaux
des crimes comme ça
bien qu'en Occident qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire
il faudrait que les hommes politiques
fassent quelque chose
je ne sais pas parce que je suis pas une
femme de politique je suis une artiste
et je ne connais pas la politique je
suis tout simplement une artiste qui qui
se bat et qui essaye de continuer son
métier
dans la liberté et que je suis déjà en
exil pour ça donc je ne pourrais pas
vous dire quoi mais je pense que
maintenant on a beau faire des concerts
des événements des manifestations mais
ça ne suffira pas maintenant c'est le
moment où les hommes politiques il
faudrait qu'ils se mobilisent alors
justement vous vous battez avec votre
art qui est celui du jeu qu'est-ce que
l'art dans tout ça
je pense que même si malheureusement
l'art n'est pas suffisant mais mais mais
je pense toujours et j'ai toujours cru
que seulement
[Musique]
le plus le plus doux pour pour parler
des horreurs dans le monde et pour faire
entendre des choses et pas seulement de
la guerre ou de de manifestations ou de
de tous les horreurs qui qui pourraient
exister dans le monde et je pense que
voilà il y aura toujours des oreilles
qui et des yeux et qui qui qui
écoutent et qui voit
à travers les œuvres d'art
ce que ce que nous nous sommes en train
de dire donc non je pense que c'est
important mais c'est pas suffisant vous
dites que cet art est doux il a été rude
avec vous il vous a vous dit à l'instant
c'est pas l'art doux mais ça le moyen le
plus doux voilà en tout cas il vous a il
vous a coûté votre vie adhérents en 2015
après avoir tourné red rose un film dans
lequel vous apparaissiez sans voile vous
avez dû quitter l'Iran il y a 7 ans vous
êtes ici en France
vous saviez à ce moment-là ce que ça
allait vous coûter à quel moment vous
êtes dit que c'était plus fort que le
reste qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
prendre cette décision là oui
c'est-à-dire que moi quand j'étais quand
j'étais en Iran
[Musique]
c'est tranche hier je le disais une
collecte artiste c'est que déjà à
l'époque je rêvais de jouer sans foulard
dans la liberté et et
je voulais ça et ce qui est étrange
c'est que malgré mon très très jeune âge
j'ai je me c'est comme si c'est comme si
dans ma tête je me disais que je préfère
être en exil mais vivre dans la liberté
que d'être dans la liberté
que d'être sous la dictature et ne pas
libres mais aujourd'hui je dis une autre
phrase je dans mon texte donc j'ai écrit
dans pour un spectacle que je préfère
être
sous la dictature mais au côté de mes
amours plutôt que d'être dans la liberté
être seul mais donc c'est donc en fait
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est quoi que
ce soit notre décision qu'on parte qu'on
reste on est vous dites qu'elle vous
brûle ouais je pense qu'on est brûlé je
pense que de toute façon hélas il y a
pas un moyen pour pour s'échapper oui
vous dites comme beaucoup d'Iraniens de
la diaspora que vous ne pouviez pas
imaginer votre vie en tout cas
professionnel en Iran et maintenant que
vous n'y êtes plus vous ne faites que
rêver d'Iran et c'est en ça que c'est
complètement schizophrénique c'est
exactement ça c'est exactement ça nous
sommes jamais dans l'endroit où nous
sommes nous sommes en permanence en
train de de rêver dans dans
d'ailleurs et je pense qu'on ne sommes
tous je pense que les exilés sont des
gens qui ont un autre rapport avec le
monde et le temps
et ça c'est ça peut être schizophrénique
oui comment être acteur c'est la
question que vous posiez dans le monde
il y a quelques temps acteurs ou actrice
quand on est censuré dans son corps vous
disiez en ce sens que vous étiez déjà
exilé dans votre désir alors que vous
étiez en Iran dans votre désir de
devenir actrice que ça n'a aucun sens
parce qu'il faut dire aux gens qui nous
regardent que les films les femmes
aujourd'hui dans les films en Iran sont
bien sûr voilées mais voilées dans les
scènes on se retrouve dans des
situations complètement
ubuesque qu'elles sont voilées dans les
scènes intimes quand elles se lève la
nuit par exemple exactement oui parce
que j'ai toujours cru que la dictature
ou la guerre
peut absolument nourrir l'imagination
d'une artiste d'un artiste mais j'ai
toujours eu du mal de
croire cela pour un acteur ou une
actrice notamment une actrice parce que
parce que nous la première chose qu'on a
besoin c'est notre liberté liberté dans
notre corps liberté dans notre tête et
lorsque déjà à la base tout est mensongé
donc tu peux pas aller très loin donc tu
es toujours coincé d'abord dans
certaines mensonges et donc pour moi
c'est impossible d'aller très loin et ça
c'est une raison pour laquelle que je
pense que depuis la Révolution ça c'est
pour moi c'est une avis très très
personnelle que nous n'avons pas eu
l'actrice dans le vrai sens du terme
depuis la révolution iranienne 1979
parce que les actrices sont tout le
temps voilées et
censurer et en ce sens quand vous voyez
ces jeunes femmes avec un infini courage
dévoilé dans les rues iraniennes
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait je je les
adore je je me mets à genoux devant
devant elle je suis je suis en
admiration totale et
à propos d'exil et à propos de
contraintes est-ce que c'est
d'aujourd'hui faire du cinéma quand on
est iranien on va parler du film que
vous portez ici en France et pour cause
pour Jafar panaïque est en ce moment en
prison dans la malheureusement connue
célèbre prison à Dery à Téhéran depuis
cet été le film s'appelle aucun ours
dans son titre en français on va en voir
quelques images
[Musique]
aucun ours donc qui a remporté le Prix
spécial du jury à la dernière Mostra de
Venise signé donc de Jafar panaik et
emprisonné c'est un film dans le film et
c'est en ça que c'est aussi un film
exceptionnel et où il y a tout le génie
de ses réalisateurs iranien il joue son
propre film on vous a vu à l'instant
enlever cette perruque celui d'un
réalisateur contraint de tourner son
film à distance oui absolument je pense
que le génie de déjà faire pané dans ce
film est notamment de encore une fois il
a il a il a il a prouvé au régime au
gouvernement qu'elle est capable de
faire du cinéma malgré tout
lui-même interdit de sortir de l'Iran et
en plus travailler avec une actrice qui
est travaillée et qui est interdit de
d'aller en Iran donc ça c'est juste
magique pour moi c'est que il est quand
même réussi de faire un film sans sa
présence et sans ma présence en Iran et
je trouve ça extraordinaire et ça c'est
quelque chose chez
chez lui j'admire énormément c'est que
je pense que quoi que ce soit à sa
condition de vie même en prison il est
capable de faire un film et j'ai été
énormément impressionnée par lui quand
j'ai travaillé avec lui même en distance
c'est que c'est que nous nous étions
absolument très
chargé d'émotion à cause de la situation
le fait qu'il n'était pas là et que vous
n'avez pas vu pendant le non parce que
moi j'ai tourné le film en Turquie et
lui il est il nous dirigeait en distance
par par WhatsApp ou zoom ou je ne sais
pas quelle application et en fait quand
je l'ai eu sur WhatsApp ou enfin je sais
pas quoi mais il était tellement
tellement concentré sur son film et sa
passion et ce qui voulait faire ce qu'il
voulait prendre des acteurs ce qui
voulait créer comme image que je me suis
dit c'est vraiment un artiste qui est
absolument passionné par son art et quoi
que ce soit sa condition de vie et c'est
ça pour moi la une vraie artiste et
c'était une grande leçon j'ai eu j'ai eu
de lui en fait
vous maintenant de porter ce film ici en
France vous l'exilez pour lui qui est en
prison qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire pour vous d'être responsable
de ça
ça peut être des fois
beaucoup de responsabilités c'est pas
très très facile parce que parce que
c'est pas facile de porter le film de
quelqu'un d'autre qui n'est pas là et
surtout un immense réalisateur donc
j'essaie toujours
je sais toujours d'être à la hauteur de
au moins dans des choses que je pourrais
dire dans le festival ou dans de ce qui
souhaiterait dire est-ce qu'il aimerait
qu'on dise de ce qui se passe en Iran
justement qui souhaiterait d'abord dire
que
d'abord
je suis sûr que maintenant il était
tanisé parce qu'il passe en Iran je le
sais parce qu'il a écrit une lettre de
prison pour
voilà par rapport à ce qui se passe
actuellement en Iran et deuxièmement je
pense que il a surtout envie de dire que
quoi que ce soit ma condition lui-même
et Monsieur Rassoul of qu'il est en
prison aussi et Mustapha je pense que il
voudrait dire que nous nous continuerons
à faire de l'art et du cinéma et
personne ne pourra nous arrêter merci
infiniment d'être venu ce matin sur ce
plateau Mina Cavani donc aucun
ours qui était au cinéma en ce moment
ici en France c'est le film donc de
Jaffa night dans lequel vous tournez il
y a aussi ce spectacle que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure que vous allez jouer je
crois au mois de janvier à Marseille
au mois de juin on va commencer dans un
festival qui s'appelle festival cabaret
curiosité dans la scène nationale de
manège au Maubeuge amoureux un mauvais
et en fait oui parce que le spectacle
produit par là-bas donc on va cette
première endroit on va on va jouer et
c'est un spectacle que j'ai moi-même
c'est vraiment mon enfant et c'est un
autobiographie
encore merci infiniment d'être venu ce
matin on se retrouve juste après la
pause pour la suite de Paris direct à
tout de suite